tv arzt dr johannes wimmer hat seine
tochter maximilian verloren im august
bekam er die schreckliche diagnose dass
seine tochter einen aggressiven
hirntumor hat sie bei starb mit gerade
mal neun monaten und jetzt schickt die
bundesregierung ihm ein standardbrief zu
dass er für seine tochter eine
kostenlose ffp zwei maske abholen könne
jetzt ist mir dr wimmer zugeschaltet
herr doktor wenn man erst mal noch mal
mein herzliches beileid zu ihrem verlust
wie wütend macht sie so ein
standardbrief den sie jetzt bekommen
haben
es ist schon ein unding muss man sagen
woher zeit auf die kassen die ämter alle
möglichen schreiben ein sehr schneller
an und machen andere aufmerksam was man
alles jetzt machen muss ja wenn man sein
kind verloren hat und was vielleicht tut
man nicht mehr bekommt und dann bekommen
wir von der bundesregierung ein brief wo
drinsteht bleiben sie gesund adressiert
an eben unsere tochter was sagt dieser
brief ihrer meinung nach aus es ist ja
noch nicht mal die stadt ja also sehr
unterschrieben mit der ich habe übrigens
auch wie vor mir ist ja unterschrieben
bleiben sie gesund ihre bundesregierung
also das ist schon das zeigt einfach in
mein datenschutz ist unser höchstes gut
ja das wird immer wieder vorangestellt
ist digitale lösung innovation werden im
gesundheitsmarkt ausgebremst weil sie
meist datenschutz datenschutz und dann
kriegt man das kleine einmaleins des
datenschutz oder der daten bewältigung
nicht also das zeigt einfach dass an so
vielen ecken ist gerade brennt und
hektisch und um sozusagen achtsamen
reagiert und agiert wird das muss ich
sagen ist schwach das sind das ist ja
nicht so wie wir in deutschland gewohnt
und zu arbeiten während der arbeiten
gründlicher arbeiten genau und das fehlt
gerade und eine mac modellen und sie
haben es gerade schon ein bisschen
angesprochen was genau steht drin in
diesem brief in dem brief steht drin
also an unsere tochter adressiert und
dann sind da auch bei gericht diese
berechtigungsscheine die sie auch
tatsächlich wo man sagen muss also auf
die hat sie ein anrecht
das sind weil sie einen den höchsten
behinderungsgrad hatte und dann können
wir uns da halt eben angeblich die
masken abholen witzigerweise fehlt
scheinbar auch die erste zusendung auf
die hingewiesen wird die ist nie
angekommen
und letzten endes schließt dann eben mit
diesem satz hat schon gesagt bleiben sie
gesund und schützen sie sich und andere
es ist halt totaler standard völlig
pietätlos rausgehauen und wir sind
sicherlich nicht die einzigen die so ein
brief bekommen sondern viele andere
eltern oder ähnlichen situation sind
oder menschen die andere angehörige
verloren haben
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren